we started a show with a touch of class
gliding through the woods and Alexis's
new hybrid engine sedan the is 300h the
luxury carmaker is hoping the new range
will help it replicate success in North
America across the pond
dafa grip design climbs it alexis is
Sandra Tibor says they have a
development center near Brussels where
various parts of cars are tuned to fit
the needs and demands of customers in
different countries Justin the front of
the new bodywork is especially striking
the grill with large air inlet shows off
the brand's new look the cars just over
four and a half meters long small wings
on the door pillars and tail lamps are
designed to make the is more aerodynamic
with a turning circle of 11.2 meters the
car maneuver as well our test driver
Montes karad is putting the is through
its paces
he's testing the f sport model with a
2.5 liter 4-cylinder engine combined
with an electric motor together they
produce 164 kilowatts the car goes from
0 to 100 kilometers an hour and eight
point three seconds and has a top speed
of 200
as a holistic spot mata says the is
isn't very sporty even though there's a
dial that switches the car to sport s or
sport as plus mode he says that when he
tries to take a corner with a bit more
speed the ESP kicks in so either the ESP
is too sensitive or the chassis isn't
quite balanced zia and Findlay OH
Devadas found a distant vision needs
Alaska hold the acronym youth good
matter says the ergonomics are good all
of the important things are well placed
he also says the buttons are more
graceful than an other toyota and lexus
models that temperature control is
particularly interesting in badia
temperature style Uncas finials endless
under a trois Cavuto speed of the a
joystick operator for the entertainment
system takes some getting used to but
Montes says with practice it's not so
bad a real problem for him is the lack
of storage space the car starts without
a key and Martha's had to put the key in
the drinks holder because there's
nowhere else at the front of the car to
put it in the bank i Dragutin vice chief
onus on snogging behind blood saba
whatever alcohol miss Ozma's it would
but Martha says he does like the fabric
used on the front and center columns and
the ceiling he says it creates a good
impression of him das macht ein 09
the egg would defend mattresses he
really likes the digital console which
shows information on this ring it's
controlled with a button on the steering
wheel monton says it's just a gadget but
a fun law you should be light so how
does the is measure up with the
entertaining and useful extras its core
is highly the most important fact for
any hybrid car is how much fuel it uses
for a sedan the figures are good the 300
h ways one thousand seven hundred kilos
and uses just 4.7 liters of gas over a
hundred kilometers as for co2 emissions
the car produces a hundred and nine
grams per kilometer
montes gives his verdict on the is as of
us Dusty's I says in terms of the design
he's totally satisfied but when it comes
down to how the car feels he says even
the f sport model isn't quite sporty
enough missing that's the kicker fed
pujoles rcz is the french carmaker's
popular sport coupe a six years ago at
the international motor show in
frankfurt the concept car wild visitors
with its extravagant design now 50,000
units later the sports car has had a
facelift
at just under four meters 30 in length
the new version of the RCZ is around 10
centimeters longer than its most serious
competitor the Audi TT the shape of the
glass roof is a real eye-catcher
but we want to get past the looks and
see how the diesel model of the coop a
really handles our test driver Sasha can
op says he's using the 120 kilowatt
version one of three optional motors but
a lot of people are really looking
forward to the new 260 horsepower motor
191 kilowatts of power it should really
pack a punch she says the 2-liter diesel
engine in our test car is no weakling
its potential torque maxes out at 340
Newton meters
and the cars other parameters are also
nothing to sneeze at the RCZ can hit 100
kilometers an hour at 8.7 seconds and
has a top speed of 225 kilometers an
hour Cujo says it burns 5.3 liters of
fuel per hundred klicks on the road
the dash is well planned with tachometer
and speedometer given pride of place
it's a sports car after all the steering
wheel sits very well in the hand with a
comfortable thumb rest a nice detail our
stick shift car has six years an
automatic transmission can only be
ordered for the smaller of the two
gasoline driven motors at need the
navigation system emerges from the
dashboard into a position well in the
drivers field of view another button
deploys the spoiler and back
Devon if Sasha says the car is just one
point 36 meters tall but still offers
plenty of headroom the leather seats
unfortunately an extra are a good
investment they feel luxurious and
comfortable with good lateral support
wouldn't I know what does either fuel
but pooja could have skipped the back
seats he says nobody would want to sit
back there the trunk has no hidden
corners but it's far from spacious and
you have to heat things up pretty high
to get them in total volume in the boot
321 leaders double that if you drop the
rear seats the RCZ isn't generous with
space and either the back passenger
seats or trunk but it isn't supposed to
be a station wagon now is it it looks
great and drives well but there are a
few rough edges the suspension is so
stiff that bumps in the road are
transferred straight to the driver and
passengers and the gears lie a little
too far away from one another on the
shifter but handling is dynamic and the
cars low center of gravity and precise
power steering get the job done
then we'll not son sister sasha says the
rccs 120 kilowatt diesel motor really
steps up to the plate and that the
turbocharger provides plenty of power to
the axles he thinks of the convertible
version of the vehicle which has a 260
horsepower 191 kilowatt gasoline motor
that Cujo revealed as a concept car at
the geneva motor show earlier this year
he actually makes it into production it
could be a really beautiful car and see
more talk firstly concession assaulted
so that but this version is no slouch
either and it's significantly cheaper
than the Audi TT competitor and Germany
the RCZ can be had for under thirty
thousand euros
for Volkswagen 2013 is the year of the
electric car just in time for the
international motor show in frankfurt VW
is celebrating the world premiere of the
e-up it's electric motor has 60
kilowatts of power and like all electric
cars tremendous torque with one fully
charged battery the e-up can take you
160 kilometres BMW is unveiling the
third generation of the x5 they double
headlights of this SUV now extend to the
trademark BMW twin kidney grills it also
has a standard xdrive all-wheel drive
and drivers will appreciate the new
head-up display the regular gas model
has 330 kilowatts of power the diesel
has 190 while the M diesel has 280
this week we're taking a real classic
city car out for a spin for over 30
years this peppy little Italian favorite
has been a mainstay on the streets of
Europe the Fiat Panda is now in its
third incarnation height attestation her
car tester Stefan Hinson says it was
easy to find his vehicle thanks to the
navigation system it's easy to remove it
from the car and then you can use it to
find your way on foot he says time to
see how it does on the road its own
stuff tested [ __ ] smells there's lots of
glass in the little car and good
visibility in all directions a big plus
in the city customers can choose between
a diesel motor version one that runs on
natural gas or one of two gasoline
driven models we're testing the smaller
but more powerful 18.9 8v twin air
thanks to a turbocharger the two
cylinder motor ponies up 63 kilowatts of
power despite having less than the
leader of displacement that's not enough
to turn the Panda into a spreader though
it takes the subcompact over 11 seconds
to hit 100 kilometers an hour from a
dead stop but Fiat at least claims its
economical the car maker says it burns
just over 4 liters of fuel per hundred
clicks on the highway Stefan says that
response is very sluggish when you step
on the gas and that the 63 kilowatts of
power don't really kick in until you hit
around 2,000 rpms but driving like this
he says will certainly affect the
manufacturers promised low fuel
consumption claims that's what the whole
decon is Lanisha my life uh but let's be
fair after all the Panda was never meant
to compete on the racetrack it's rounded
corners and friendly exterior are meant
to attract buyers who are looking for a
more cuddly ride no sharp edges here the
entire car is a study in curves even the
geometric shapes in the grille running
lights and bumpers are organic
the first generation of pandas one heart
says boxes on wheels and the latest
version is still very boxy but every
corner is rounded off
and with the panda design doesn't get in
the way of functionality the trunk has
225 cubic liters of space and lowering
the rear seats expands that to 870
litres it's benign off to a middle zone
Stefan says that the Panda provides a
very smooth ride once it gets rolling
but in fátima putting the car in City
mode makes the steering wheel more
responsive he says panda also has a
stop-start system and the gears shift
very smoothly although there's plenty of
plastic in the interior to cut costs the
pendant doesn't feel cheap the dashboard
elements fit the car's overall rounded
personality a bare-bones version of the
Panda cells in Germany for less than
10,000 euros to save space all the seats
have narrow back rests a good idea but a
seating test shows that a taller than
average driver makes for a very tight
squeeze and back
there's enough Headroom but adults that
have to sit in the rear probably won't
enjoy it for long in short says Stefan
the Fiat Panda drives well it's agile
and small enough that finding parking in
the city shouldn't pose much of a
problem the perfect car for students for
young people he says if it wasn't for
that little question about fuel
consumption bed and darkness they're
split father Xavier
the old-timer Grand Prix brings tens of
thousands of visitors to the Nurburgring
circuit every year the spectacle is also
a chance for car owners to show off
their prized possessions to the public
whether they're newer models or classic
racing cars
the reeses themselves are almost an
afterthought but they're still full of
excitement here his story cars produced
up to nineteen sixty take to the track
on the famous nordschleife a-- they show
why motorsport fans from around the
world were fascinated by them
in the pit lane fans throng to their
favorite car makers tents many have
brought their own automobiles cars they
use every day that have racing in their
jeans the thrill of competition is what
their owners dreama
Portia is one of the brand's taking part
this year the company's got a special
anniversary the 911 is turning 50 years
old one of the world's most iconic cars
is being celebrated with a huge meat of
911 owners they're proud of one of
Germany's great exports declutter this
man says the 911s quality style and
technology set it apart he's a mage in
Germany does this this owner says it's a
car no one needs but everyone wants
false or fear this enthusiast says
Porsche is a down-to-earth brand he can
drive his car anywhere because it's
genuine and simple tonight complex off
in the NHS auto the highlight for the
911 fans is a parade around the
Nordschleife these models show why the
911 is the standard other sports cars
are measured against it's suitable for
both the racetrack and the open road
rather than an eccentric toy for the
rich and famous it's a car that's passed
the test of time
back at the Porsche tent the auto giants
have some exhibits that deserve a spot
in a museum the 1984 Porsche Carrera was
a masterpiece of aerodynamics and have a
CW value of just 0.27 meaning it had
barely any drag it still influences
design today and there's the 1987
Carrera speedster only 2103 were ever
made it's reminiscent of the porsche 356
speedster bringing together the old and
the new racing legend Derek Bell is
joining in the celebrations he won the
lemond 24-hour race five times well the
fascination is that the car is just is
unique because it's been there for 50
years no other manufacturers manage to
call a car in 911 or or a Jaguar 12 or
whatever it's the 911 and it's been
there for 50 years and it's yes gets
better every year they improve it and
make it better and better and better
honey you can't be that can you can't
beat because the shape stays not roughly
the same but the rest of the car just
gets better even the interior is better
the engines better the suspensions where
the aerodynamics and so therefore the
car stays there and it's unique there's
no other car in the world has done that
demand for classic and vintage cars is
growing all the time that makes it more
important than ever for carmakers to
maintain their history for Porsche a
nurse about 35,000 original parts are
still available to make repairs on older
models